SPEAKER: The advice I would give
to educators who are teaching
this course would be to first,
the class had a very technical
component in terms of the
readings-- maybe not--
it had a very--
one of the components
of the class
was very focused on having
readings that really opened up
the discussions.
A lot of these were taken
from different sources,
different-- some from
theoretical linguistics,
to just general readings from
things like James Baldwin,
or open op-eds from newspapers.
I think having a strong--
I think having a lot
of reading material
that can strike from
different places
but that also is
very good or that
gives to a lot of
thinking, I think
that's something that really
was one of the best things I
like about this course.
The second was-- is
how this course is also
a place for dialogue
to examine ourselves.
Since we all speak
a language, we all
have a sense of identity.
So thinking about all
these things with--
from our point of view or from
our lives is very important.
So being able to have
a space of discussion,
a space in which people
can tell their own stories,
probably for most-- a
good part of the class,
I think that's one of the
essential parts to making this
a truly learning experience
that helps you read the word--
and read the world
and not just the word.